You guys know that I try my best to stay out
of the day to day political bickering and
focus more on big ideas and the philosophies
which are behind all the fighting.
This doesn't mean I'm completely ignoring
the issue of the moment, be it North Korea,
the gun debate, or the general state of Trumpism,
but focusing on why people believe what they
believe is more valuable to me than adding
fuel to the fire of whatever the story of
the day might be.
Toss in a healthy dose of political gridlock
and we seem to have lots of people who are
yelling but very few people who are doing.
There's one issue happening in American politics
right now which is a great example of the
stagnation we face but that is totally flying
under the radar..
Right now dozens of countries, some of them
key strategic allies, don't have US ambassadors
because the senate has refused voted on their
confirmation.
Accordingl to the rules right now, the senate
needs 30 hours of debate time to confirm an
ambassadorship.
You can imagine with all the nonsensical waste
in DC how impossible it would be to spend
30 hours debating each of the new ambassadorships
when a new administration comes in.
We'd be talking about literally thousands
of hours of debate for a branch of government
which can't agree which flavor of yogurt should
be served at the capital hill commissary.
Back in 2014, when the Democrats controlled
the Senate, then majority leader Harry Reid
used what is known as "the nuclear option"
to get many Obama appointees through the senate.
In effect, Harry Reid changed the rules so
that a simple majority, rather than a 60 vote
super majority, would be enough to confirm
ambassadors, federal judges and other positions.
Though I was firmly on the Left at the time
and had no issue can I remember with the Obama
appointees, I was against Reid using such
a drastic tactic.
To me, if you changed the rules when you're
in power, it's incredibly obvious and probably
quite deserved when those same rules will
be used against your team when you're not
in power.
You can righty blame Republicans for not voting
on the Obama appointees in 2014, just as right
now you can rightly blame democrats for not
voting on Trump appointees in 2018.
This is exactly why people rightfully hate
the political machine in Washington.
It either does nothing or it changes the rules
to suit itself while usually leaving the people
its supposed to serve far behind.
The Republicans, now led by Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell, could use what is known as
the Nuclear option right now, just as Reid
and the Democrats did back in 2014.
For whatever reason, McConnell refuses to
do so.
Some are saying he has such an old school
affinity for the rules of the Senate, that
he doesn't want to stoop to what Reid did.
In a certain way this seems like a principled
position, but at this point in American politics,
I wonder if clinging onto the old ways, while
your your idelogical opponents chisel away
at those very institutions at every opportunity
makes much sense at all.
Another wrinkle to this story: is that highest
ranking ambassadorship we have open, Germany,
has been offered to former US spokesman for
the UN, Richard Grennell.
Richard is the longest serving UN spokesman
in history, working for four different US
ambassadors.
He's also served several other positions in
the government, as well as worked for a few
other high level campaigns.
By every measure he is supremely qualified
and I've seen plenty of people on both sides
of the aisle praise him as the type of person
we need more of in politics.
Richard and I have become friends over the
past few years and I can personally tell you
that he's decent guy who truly wants to serve
his country.
Oh, and there's one other piece to this: Richard
happens to be gay.
You may remember back in 2012 he was briefly
a spokesman for the Romney campaign until
the media decided to attack a openly gay man
for daring to work for the Republican candidate
Mitt Romney thus causing Richard to step down
from the campaign because he didn't want to
be a distraction.
Apparently although Romney felt it was just
fine to hire a gay man, and Richard felt it
was totally ok to work for Romney the media
just wouldn't let it be.
Gay conservatives like Richard, much like
black conservatives like Larry Elder or women
conservatives like Nikki Haley, challenege
the orthodoxy that the Democrats must own
all of these groups.
I mention Richard's sexuality not because
it is important or even relevant unless you
play the identity politics game as so many
do.
In effect, the Democrats are blocking an extremely
qualified, openly gay man from serving his
country.
Aren't the Democrats and Lefties supposed
to be for gays?
Isn't that part of their intersectional word
view?
Immutable characteristics often trump qualifications
if you subscribe to this line of thinking.
Shouldn't this also mean supporting gay people
who's political positions you might disagree
with because you believe in their ability
to think for themselves?
Or perhaps the so-called tolerant side isn't
really pro gay or pro-any minority, they are
actually on pro those who believe as they
do.
Now obviously you know I don't think anyone
should be confirmed because of their sexuality,
nor should their sexuality matter in the least
when it even comes to being nominated in the
first place.
I just think that this particular case is
interesting on so many levels.
We have the gridlock of Washington, with Democrats
refusing to vote on Trump nominees.
We have a majority leader in McConnell that
refuses to use his option to confirm nominees
even though the previous Senate leader Reid
did exactly just that.
We have dozens of qualified candidates waiting
to due their civic duty and we have just as
many countries waiting for our ambassadors
to move their and get to work.
Caught in all of that mess in a good man,
Richard Grennel, who I happen to know personally,
who doesn't want extra credit for being gay,
but just wants to get to work.
How can you make a difference in all this?
Call your local Senator and ask the assistant
at their office why they aren't voting on
these nominess.
And You can also call Mitch McConnell at his
DC office by calling (202) 224-2541.
Actually, I'm gonna give him a call right
now...